when Sandler called you to say hey I
want I want you to do my daughter's Bat
Mitzvah is it that Sandler is so big
that he is such a big entertainer that
you can't say no because I would think
this is unusual friend I mean we were
your friends it wasn't like it was a
cold call it wasn't a tableau no no and
you feel he was imposing on you did he
was nosing you in a way he knew I love
dummy the [ __ ] that's why he knew I
was you know did you feel weird was it
like turning around on the boys with the
chair in front of the advertiser no it
by the way it was not nearly as formal
as it sounds like he hit me up right
before I think a week or two texted you
and well he texted me and I will you
never give out your text number again no
no he's great but yeah my number I told
you we hang out we play basketball stuff
no but he actually was actually was
really funny is it this might have been
something I had not been had the time to
do had I not just literally just left
the voice so I had all this free time
and so he texted me and I'm like [ __ ]
like why not this sounds great and my
wife will come it'll be awesome um and
it was like kind of come sing a song or
two no big deal
James you played - yeah like when Adam
called you say hey we're doing about he
was so nice to me you know cuz you do
those things a lot of times people you
know you're just talking to Adam
ignoring to me actually paid attention
to you totally and he introduced me to
like Dustin Hoffman and cool Kevin
Nealon it was all I was also by the way
it was like it was star-studded Bar
Mitzvah it was like it was like you know
I'm Billy Madison when he like Celebi
graduates like the third grade and he
had some crazy [ __ ] rage like that's
kind of what it felt like it was funny